hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
homatopoetic sells therapy products
determining potency and stability
i'm christy jewell of labrutz and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinth
and sponsored by stem cell technologies
for more information on our sponsor
please visit stemcell.com
i would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab on
the left to let your friends and
colleagues know about today's
live event now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on that support tab
down at the top of your presentation
window or you can use that ask a
question
box to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
this presentation is educational and it
does offer continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker
dr jackie dingman senior scientific
advisor
hematopoiesis stem cell technologies
for a complete biography on dr damon
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr damon you may now begin your
presentation
thanks christy for that uh introduction
let's dive in now to
a stem cell sponsored webinar today
hematopoietic cell therapy products
determining potency and stability
the learning objectives for the webinar
today will really be to define the cfu
assay and its characteristics as a
biological tool in identifying
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
to recognize the utility of the cf2
assay in processing and manufacturing
of human aquatic cell therapy products
and also to identify publications
using the cfu assay to verify the
potency and stability of products
just to give you an outline of the
sections we'll go through today we'll
start
with hematopoietic stem cell therapy and
do a bit of a review
of the regulatory requirements in this
space um then have a really short review
on the applications of expansion of
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
extivo
we'll then really dive into the assays
to quantify hematopoietic stem and
progenitor cells
and more particularly in section four
discuss the cfu assay
applications of the cfu assay and
especially applications when it comes to
potency instability
and then we'll end with a little bit of
tips and tricks on how to standardize
the cfu assay
okay let's start then with hematopoietic
stem cell therapy
so as we know there's a long history of
bone marrow transplants in the treatment
of hematological disorders
this is a long history that started
really in the 50s with the first bone
marrow transplant to cure leukemia
and we know that it's been a curative
treatment for
40 years more than 40 years for blood
cancer such as leukemia lymphoma
bone marrow disorder such as aplastic
anemia as well as genetic diseases like
sickle cell anemia
in fact bone marrow was the sole source
for many years and as you can see
by the graph here on the right hand side
which shows the number of transplants in
the u.s from 1992 to 2016
the blue bars indicated indicate bone
marrow as the source
and up until 2000 it was the only source
but in 2004 mobilized peripheral blood
actually
became more of the major source for
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
really due to advances in technology
that has allowed
the ability to mobilize and collect
large numbers of hematopoietic stem
progenitor cells in a less invasive way
cord blood has also popped up here and
you can see that by the orange bars
particularly around again 2004 really
from
evidence in 1996 to 2001
that cord blood and bone marrow actually
had they
showed that there was no difference in
leukemia-free survival rates
when looking at treatment for both
children and adults
recognizing in most cases this was young
adults because their limitations of
course the core blood
is that you can only collect so much
blood and only get so many cells
when it comes to some stem cell therapy
products
one has to recognize that there are
requirements for these products when it
was fresh and it was bone marrow
um these requirements were not
historically required because everything
was done fresh but now that
things like mobilize peripheral blood
and cord blood have entered this arena
we have to recognize that these cells
are somewhat processed
red blood cells are often removed and in
some cases
these cells can be manipulated and
changed with the new therapies
so you really have to recognize that you
have to
really look at stem cell-derived
cellular products
and ensure that there's reproducibility
and consistency
which is inherently a problem due to the
donor variability of the starting
material
so it's important that the product
quality
both the purity and the potency needs to
be established at various stages of
manufacturing
and the purity means really the cell
composition
and including the contaminating cell
types and these need
are typically identified using flow
cytometry
the potency needs really to identify the
capacity of the product to
affect the given result and the fda
generally doesn't accept viability
as the only measure of potency because
there's
issues with assuming that viability
means that the cells can function
if you look here on the right hand side
at the table
this is really a um outline
of a table that examines the release
criteria
after retroviral transduced for
retrovirally transduced hematopoietic
stem cell products
and this is from a recent paper and from
molecular therapy
in 2017 and you can see that the
requirements for safety testing
include sterility of course uh purity
identity and potency
and for purity they use flow based on
the really the only marker that
identifies hematopoietic stem cells and
that's the
cd34 positivity and for them they wanted
their release criteria
to be greater than 90 percent if
possible or report the value recognizing
that when you do the clinical
trial you'll actually find out if 90 is
actually necessary
or if you can get away with something
like 85
usually doing the clinical trial allows
you to really identify the ranges
that are acceptable for the purity of
something like this
with regards to the potency the
viability has been
identified as being required and
in this case greater than seventy
percent postfa very specifically using
trypan blue
but they also ask that the cfu assay be
done and
a value report a value reported
but really what value would that be and
the fact of the matter is it really kind
of depends again on
the treatment that you're doing in the
manipulation that you're doing
so if you started with cells that had a
high cfu frequency then post
modification you would really want to
expect that
reporting the value that there would be
a percentage that would be acceptable
like 80 or something so these are really
key important measurements that need to
be
confirmed before you can release
products for therapy
in fact if you look at the guidance for
the industry potency tests for cellular
and gene
therapy products that the fda's released
one very important statement
in 21cfr 11 is that
no lot of any licensed product shall be
released by the manufacturer
prior to the completion of tests for
conformity
with standards applicable for such
product these mean
again and you can see it's the same as
the last slide
but these tests include values for
potency sterility
purity and product identity and really
if you look
at what a potency assay should be a good
potency assay
it should be something that you can
actually validate
it should also demonstrate product
activity it should have a quantitative
readout
and it should also indicate product
stability and consistency
normally these start as you can see at
the beginning of the discovery
phase when you're developing a new
therapy potency assays are really at the
developmental stage there
and then as you go through your clinical
trials the more assays that you have
that describe
the potency of the product the more able
you are to find one or two
that actually very specifically
correlate with
good clinical outcome
so when we look at for example one of
the only
at this point fda registered cell
therapy products these are cord blood
cells
we recognize that there are very strict
regulatory requirements
when using cord blood products for
basically hematopoietic cell therapy all
cord blood banks for example
need to be fda registered and most are
also accredited
by aabb in fact other regulatory
bodies and both of these require that
you test cells
pre-freeze as well as postpone to really
ensure that the potency of the cells are
good and they
recommend using the cfu assay as you can
see in these guidances
that are displayed on this slide
so let's then talk a little bit about
the expansion of hematopoietic stem
cells at stevo
and why this is so important to cell
therapy products
okay really breaking it down to the
therapeutic applications of the
expansion of hematopoietic stem cells
like vivo
are listed here and the reality is
expansion of hematopoietic
cd34 cells have really been the holy
grail
of hematopoietic research for many many
years
and mostly because of the important
therapeutic ramifications
so expansion of cd34 means the expansion
of the long-term hematopoietic
self-renewing stem cell that can really
repopulate as you can see by the diagram
all the blood cells in a compromised
host
so expansion of cd34 from cord blood has
actually been
looked at for the last 20 years to
really try and improve
since core blood has a limited number to
improve the numbers
of hematopoietic cells that are have
that in grafting function
as well as improve the recovery time for
allogeneic transplants in adults with
leukemia and really open up
that pool of cells that could be used to
treat those patients
also of course what we've learned from
how to expand cord blood
can be transferred to how to expand
mobilized peripheral blood
and that's going to become important as
people try and scale up
gene therapy applications for autologous
transplant options
and then there's also been a lot of
therapeutic applications for
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
when it comes to lineage specific
differentiation and a lot of research
that really started
in the 80s and 90s both focused on
the conditions required to expand
hematopoietic cells and culture so they
we could really study them that led us
to understand
a lot of the conditions required not
only to expand
cord blood and other cd34 purified cells
but also
led us to understand what are the
critical factors
to really induce lineage-specific
differentiation
this is important and there's been
always this clinical
application of doing clinical scale
exeval production for example
of red blood cells and platelets to have
a safe and adequate supply of blood
cells
we know all the conditions the issue and
the reason it's still being studied
today
is really how do we optimize this and
make it cost effective
the other one of course that is booming
right now and
is probably really only in its infancy
is the generation of lineage committed
genetically altered cells for targeted
immunotherapies so we're actually also
now looking at
using hematopoietic stem cells and
properties of t
cells for example to really increase the
quantity of those cells genetically in
and
genetically engineer them so they can be
targeted not only for blood cancers
but other types of cancers so a lot of
applications
based on just the expansion of
hematopoietic stem cells extivo
and due to 30 40 years of research we
now have a lot of
knowledge about the conditions that's
required
in fact one thing that is a certainty
when it comes to that we've realized
that when it comes to trying to expand
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
it's vegal
is being aware of the regulation of
hematopoietic stem cell self-renewal
so whenever you put these really rare
hematopoietic
cd34 positive cells xv1 culture
the certainty that we've realized over
the last 40 years
is those cells start to lose their
stemness
and it's really because of the fact
they've been removed from the niche
i mean there's a lot of niche factors in
the niche that
are we're still finding actually um
which ones are critical
but most of them involve in either
intrinsic factors like transcription
factors
or entrance extrinsic factors like
growth factors
cytokines and what we've realized more
lately are small molecules based on the
fact
that we've now identified that it's
really the self-renewing
population and that first symmetric
division as you can see in the
diagram on this slide that is really
critical to
allowing the very specific
anatomic stem cell to divide and
maintain
its ability to engraft in a host
because if you actually if that cell has
an asymmetric division
then you start that process of
differentiation and lineage maturation
so the key is as soon as you put
hematopoietic stem cells in culture
they start to differentiate and really
um recent evidence in the last 10 15
years
has allowed research researchers who
have been studying this phenomenon for
many years to identify novel small
molecules
which we call differentiation blockers
now that have
allowed one to really find factors
that'll
allow that first self-renewing division
and expand that population
more than we've ever had been able to in
the past
so to be able to show that of course a
lot of the research has depended on
a lot of assays of how to quantify
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
so i'll just review those as well as
outline some of the applications
of how those can be used
so if we look at this slide we realize
that there really are
two basic ways to quantify hematopoietic
stem cells
the first is phenotypically and that
really measures
physical cell properties based on cell
surface markers that those cells have
and as we've mentioned expression of
cd34 is really the most common marker
used to identify
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
and as cells differentiate
they lose that expression of cd34
but they also then become positive for
under other lineage
markers that are specific more for the
mature cells and
a lot of these are listed here and you
can see based on
the images um which of the cell types
and which of the lineages express
which of these what we call lineage
markers
so to be able to identify true
hematopoietic stem cells
they should be cd34 positive and lineage
negative
and we've since learned that there are
other markers that we can look at
like cd90 positivity and cd49f
and c kit that will really help define
different subsets
uh of the cd34 population that have
some of which we really want to define
are those that are
in the engraftable population versus
those that are
just starting to become fake committed
better than a phenotypic assay
especially when you're trying to
prove something is a functional assay so
really there are a couple of properties
of hematopoietic and stem and progenitor
cells that really define those
populations
that allow us to measure them based on
those functions and again thanks to 40
years of research that showed us what
those are
and for hematopoietic stem cells that's
really an in vivo transplantability or
engraftman assay because that's our
expectation that the hematopoietic stem
cell
can engraft a compromised host so
there's models now to show that and
measure that
as well as in vitro assays which are a
little easier to perform
but allow us to really identify
progenitor and stem cells
based on their very unique ability to
still have the ability
as an adult stem cell to proliferate and
differentiate
into all the blood cell types and
and all the cell blood lineages
so in this slide you can see that there
really is two
main assays that are used and pretty
much all publications
uh these days actually show both of
these if they are looking for effects on
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
the first
actually is called the skid repopulating
assay
or which is an assay that was really
developed
in 1997 by john dixlab and it really is
an
individual quantitative assay that
measures the engraftment potential
of the hematopoietic stem cell to
repopulate the hematopoietic system
in a compromised immune deficient
xenotransplant
mouse model so it's named after the
original strain that was used which was
mod skid
today however there's been a lot of uh
improvement
on that strain and you can get all kinds
of versions of what we call nsg mice now
that work in the same way the other
is the colony forming unit cell assay or
the cfu assay
that really measures the progeny
of that long-term hematopoietic stem
cell so the skid assay really measures
just that ability of that long-term
hematopoietic stem cell
to repopulate a host for the lifetime of
the animal
but the colony forming assay really
looks at the progeny of that cell
which are the progenitors that actually
control
and maintain the right number of blood
cells
on an everyday basis and then this assay
is actually a clonal assay
which then means by default our
definition
that it is a quantitative assay that
identifies the frequency
and lineage commitment potential of
functionally viable
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
and i've just included some references
here
so that you can actually take a look at
how long ago these were done and how
impressive that is
okay so when you look at acids to
quantify hematopoietic stem and
progenitor cells
really the workhorse has been the cfu
assay
um it really can it demonstrates stem
and progenitor cell
activity it's a clonal assay
when you look at the diagram here you'll
actually see some images
of measuring a progenitor cell so the
difference between a progenitor cell and
all the mature cells
is that unique ability to grow if it's a
very early progenitor
it might have multi-potential which
means that it
actually can make cells of different
cell mature cells of different cell
types
and you can see that by the cfu gemm
image shown here where you see red cells
as well as other cells surrounding it
versus the ability to actually look at
more lineage specific progenitors
for example bfues are from the erythroid
lineage
and cf2gm from the myeloid lineage and
the ability to actually
watch a single cell in semi-solid media
expand and grow in culture in a
spatially
identifiable and separated way then
allows you to really count and look at
how many what is the frequency per
cell's plated and
am i really getting the appropriate and
the normal erythroid
and myeloid ratio as well as platelets
you can also look at progenitors
for cfu mk to confirm that not only
the cells are healthy and working but if
you've manipulated them
has any of that changed so it's a clonal
assay which makes it quantifiable
and it gives you the frequency of
erythroid myeloid and
platelet progenitors megakaryocytes
in really the ratio of if you have a
progenitor
it's one colony and it's one cfu so that
is where
that allows you that measurement and
through the years of course this assay
has been used in many different ways
and if you look at the references that
we've included on this slide
you can see that in some cases people
that have looked
and compared what they see in a cfu
assay to the outcome
in patients following bone marrow
transplant
they can show that the cfu assay is a
very good potency assay
that strongly correlates with the
engraftment potential
of these sonataquatic stem cell products
in patients
when it comes to applications for
quantifying hematopoietic stem and
progenitor cells
this is actually something that
people that are looking at novel
therapies
especially using gene therapy have
used to really test the efficacy of
their manufactured
product so really if you're looking at
purified
that if you're wanting to treat prisons
for example with
a genetic disorder like sickle cell
anemia you can purify
the cd34 cells from the patient
and then with genetic editing
basically change those cells correct
them
in other words manipulate them but then
they also need to be extend
expanded before they're return to the
patient and potentially cure that
patient's disease
how much expression do you need to cure
that disease of course
depends on the disease so assays really
then
are can allow the ability to give
indicators of a successful
transplant prior to in grafton in vivo
by using the two acids i just
described engraftment assay which can
assess the long-term effects
of the gene therapy that you've done you
want to would want to make sure in the
most model
that the expression of whatever it is
that you've changed it actually
is long-term and will be expressed for
the lifetime of the individual but also
how much of it needs to be expressed
to basically make a change so that uh it
cures the disease
and this can all be confirmed using that
assay
to confirm expansion and of cells that
still have that engraftment potential
we see a few assay is also important and
easier to do of course
and it will allow the assessment of the
progenitor frequency
post manipulation and make sure that you
get recovery
and normal recovery and function of all
the
functional ability of those cells to
differentiate to all the different
mature cell lineages
so when it comes to the applications
actually of these assays that quantify
hematopoietic stem progenitor cells
i really encourage you to look at this
publication
as shown on this slide it's really a
good case study of
identifying the challenges that one
needs to think about when they're
getting into the
gene therapy space and trying to make
cells
uh hematopoietic stem cell products to
help
uh cure people with these genetic
disorders um and
this publication really highlights the
large-scale production challenges
that exist when trying to genetically
engineer
hematopoietic stem cells really
recognizing that one of the things you
have to overcome
is a limitation to the number of cells
that you have
typically patients with disease don't
mobilize very well
so it's important to know the conditions
and optimize those
to to get enough cells to allow complex
genetic manipulations
without losing the stem cell function
so this paper really defines the optimal
clinical
and clinically applicable strategy to
purify hematopoietic stem cells and
determine conditions for ex-evil
expansion to preserve that important
engraftment function and if i encourage
you really encourage you to look at this
paper because it also
shows that when you're trying to expand
cord blood or bone marrow cd34 cells
there's some
pretty dramatic differences cord blood
has a lot more
proliferative potential so it can be
expanded you get more cells and you can
do it for longer you have to be really
careful that bone marrow or mobilized
peripheral blood is going to be your
source
because those don't expand as well you
have to really understand you have to
use
these sort of small molecule inhibitors
that have recently been identified
that are promoters of hematopoietic stem
cells self-renewing divisions
to really get enough cells for that so
i've summarized that actually on this
next slide
this is a busy slide but i really wanted
to highlight here
that you really have to look and this
paper defines it very well
the protocols and the tools and how to
standardize those for your
expansion application to make sure that
it's efficacious for
gene therapy some of the protocol things
you have to think about for example is
to standardize your workflow
what are the subtypes of cd-34 are you
going to purify or just looking at
purifying total cd34 and
modifying all of these and then
optimizing the expansion time
as i mentioned they really highlight
using the engraftman assay then the nsg
most
assay that less is better when you're
trying to
actually maintain the potency of that
graftable hematopoietic stem cell
included our course are optimizing your
treatment protocols
what cytokines do you add what is the
cocktail you want to do
are you going to add small molecules how
much expansion do you need
and in this uh publication they actually
highlight that the small molecules sr1
especially
has allowed a huge amount of expansion
that they weren't otherwise able to get
without adding these molecules
and also recognizing that enhanced
transduction efficiency for the viral
vectors that they used
so thinking about these things and
optimizing your protocols and strategies
for expression of genetically modified
and genetically modified population is
really important whether you're working
with viruses or doing non-viral
approaches
the tools and reagents are obviously
also highly important
making sure that you have a consistent
supply of well optimized media
for the case of expanding cd34 cells
these should be serum free
culture medias and
also looking at the early acting
cytokines which ones are you going to do
use and in fact about again 30 40 years
of
literature of labs looking at what early
acting cytokines to use
this has not changed honestly since the
90s everyone at that point identified
the three main players as stem cell
factor flip 3 ligand and typo
some have added il-3 some have added
il-6
what's changed in the last 10 years is
in
most cases just in the last five is this
idea of
small molecules in other words
identifying and screening for molecules
that we know
are perpetuating that self-renewing
population
is still something that and the reason
why hematopoietic stem cell expansion
is still the holy grail in research we
still don't understand the mechanisms of
these
but we can certainly tell that they are
important in the expansion and you can
really see an increase in the number of
cd34
cells you get using these so that you
have a lot more cells
to do manipulation and of course once
you do your molecular
manipulation making sure that you have
good assays that are going to
tell you if it's working and i've
outlined those for you
using the skid repopulating cell assay
from graftman
as well as understanding the purity
making sure you have
enough cd34 cells as identified by flow
or any other
contaminating self populations and also
looking at the
ability and functional ability using the
cfu assay
can really identify that you have
maintained a good frequency of those
progenitors
and you haven't actually changed or lost
any of the
progenitor types
so you've heard a lot now about the cfu
assay i'm
going to dive in a little bit now and
talk more specifically about the cfu
assay
and describe its some publications that
show
the usefulness of this assay especially
when it comes to looking at potency and
stability
so the cfu assay has a lot of
applications and if you remember at the
beginning of this talk we talked about
the fact that the fda has very specific
guidelines for cardboard banks that are
making
hematopoietic cell therapy products and
there are actually to date a number of
cord blood cell therapy products that
have been approved by the fda
um you can see an example here of an
insert from one of these
packaged insert from alicorn which is a
supplier
of one of these approved cell therapy
products
and that insert and inserts for all of
the products that
cell therap or cord blood cell therapy
products that i've seen actually
include information and very detailed
information on how to receive the
product
how to prepare the product how to dilute
the product as well as how to infuse it
and ensure that you actually maintain a
sample
that you can do qc on so that you can
confirm that the product that you have
has not been
affected from the transport from the
core blood lab
to the clinical site this is really
important that you put in temperature
monitors
when and monitoring systems when you're
shipping cells
and it's actually up to the cord blood
bank
as you noticed in the other guidances to
ensure that they've looked pre
and post thought that they have
um hematopoietic stem progenitor cells
that are actually going to grow out
and they use the cfu acid or analogous
potency assay but they recommend the cfu
to ensure that that's the case they want
to confirm that though
that if they've shipped it to you
typically that happens in prior shippers
that with if the temperature monitor
says it's okay
that is probably a good indication that
the product that you have in your hands
is good
but assuming that you don't you don't
thought inappropriately and that it's
thought well
that this assay then can really tell you
um at the end what the
product that the patient got was and
what was the
stability and what was the potency of
that product so
when you're looking at the quality
control here it asks you in the product
insert to make sure you do a nucleated
cell count definitely a viability test
you want to make sure that the cells
that you're injecting
are viable in fact when you order these
they kind of give you the idea of well
this unit is the right one that you have
the right compatibility for your patient
but it and it has
x amount of cells and that's important
because you know the weight of your
patient
and it's a one of the dope ways um when
you're doing a transplant
to ensure the patient gets the right
dose it's really based on the viability
and more particularly the viability of
cd34 cells so those have to be part of
the quality control test
they also ask you to do the cfu assay of
course
for potency and the antimicrobial test
to make sure that you have the sterility
so these qtc tests really
are because the product is preserved and
you want to make sure
that it is stable that it's transported
okay and that the product that you gave
the patient
is actually you can confirm with the cfu
assay
was actually a good product in fact core
blood banks now
and a lot of people and a lot of
institutes that are
freezing and using and storing cell
therapy products
are now have to write into their
programs
that you need some kind of stability
test that is
actually performed annually to ensure
a good quality product and those are new
regulations from jc that came out
in 2015.
and this slide actually shows you that
the cfu assay
not only is important as a qc test but
as i mentioned
the dose that's used when you're
actually
collecting hematopoietic stem cell
product cells before you're going to use
them for therapy
you usually base that dose on the number
of cd34 cells
and historically that was done of course
because we were talking about bone
marrow that's fresh
or in the early days of mobilized
peripheral blood
that you could actually do flow identify
the purity of cd34
do it at the right at the time it only
takes an hour or two to do flow
and that way you can ensure that if you
needed to mobilize the patient for
longer
and that their cd 34 wasn't up to the
level that you
needed them you could actually use flow
more specifically
to make sure that you did get enough
cells from that patient
if at all possible in some cases
patients that don't mobilize well are
actually then
recognized after three or four days of
mobilization with gcss that it's not
enough
so they're actually asked to the
the patients get mosabil to really
improve the number of cd34 cells they
have
so for transplantation purposes they try
and get a dose of at least 10 to the six
cd34 cells per kilogram and that is
uh not everybody can measures the cd34
cells the same way
flow can be a little bit um
unstandardized and different people can
look at it differently based on gating
strategies
so there was a protocol that was
actually published in 1996 to try and
standardize this
unfortunately surveys have shown that
not everybody uses that protocol
but nonetheless it actually when you
look at a lot of
the clinical trials and successful
transplants it usually sort of
recognizes that if you inject 10 to the
6 cd34 cells
that should be a good dose for the
transplant but
injecting it is one thing waiting to see
the excess of the transplant is another
you won't actually see the success of a
transplant until about
three two to three or four weeks after
the patient has been injected
and at that point it's good that if
you've set up the cfu assay at the same
time
you actually have confidence as to
whether it was the cells that was the
problem
or everything else that the patient has
to go through in that transplant process
so the cfu assay has always really
provided that data it's retrospective
yes uh information about the functional
activity
but it's something that's quite critical
when you think you've had the right dose
you've injected your patient
and then you realize three or four weeks
later
they're not engrafting if you have set
up the cdf you ask me and you had no
growth
you'd be very quickly looking for
another donor in fact
some recent publications by dr
watts and lynch here and i show this
this reference is included down here
that you know if
you've got a poor mobilizer and this
happens quite a bit with patients with
disease
you basically have no choice you inject
them anyway
and if you've done a cfu assay typically
what you find
um with the correlates with good
engraftment
is when patients actually can present
with
2x10 to the 5 csugm per kilogram
so if you go back look at your the cell
numbers and identify
yes we have um you know greater than two
by ten to the five cf2 gm that we
injected
then you know that maybe the engraftman
is just taking a little bit longer
and you're not looking for another donor
right away so
it does give you that retrospective data
but it's a lot of comfortability to make
sure
the assay did work that the transplant
at least the patient got the right cells
in that case
the other of course issue is that um
even more recently we've realized that
cd34
when you're looking at viability on
crowd preserved samples works
until it doesn't and this uh
slide really illustrates a situation
where it didn't
um and there was some issues from a
hospital
the great ormond hospital in london
where they had
uh realized that there were patients
with delayed engraftment
who had received adequate post viable
cell counts
but they couldn't understand what was
going on and why their transplants were
delayed
so there was actually an investigation
that was started because of this
and uh this sort of outlines
um sort of what happened as far as
the bbc news that came out on this
uh incident and dr mike watts again was
involved in investigating this and
really
identif uh did a independent
investigation and a publication
to show that the assessment of post
cd 34 viability is unlikely actually to
be adequate to really guarantee
functional activity and he recognized
and you can see that
in the diagram here based on freezer
profiles that if he
took cells and froze them at different
centers
and different by passive freezing
methods
compared to the freezer program that
they were using at the gosh hospital
where these patient cells had been
collected and stored
that you could see that there was
definitely a difference in the freezer
program
profiles that the when you look at the
gosh hospital
the temperature dropped very quickly
and then in fact in a non-optimal way
you really want
when you're doing freezing programs for
hematopoietic stem cells to really
freeze them
at a degree per minute and that has to
be maintained till at least
past -50 degrees otherwise that can
really affect the functional output of
the cells
the cd34 viability looked great but when
he actually compared
the cfugm or cfu
output from these different freezing
profiles
recognized that the data showed really
that all of them were fine except the
one from the gosh
rate control freezer where that steep
curve
in the freezer profile profile was
observed there was actually
no growth of the cfu in that in those
samples whereas the cd-34 actually
showed
some decent viability so it's one of
those things that yes cd34
viability works until it doesn't and if
you really want to be sure
on fod cells that you've got cells that
are able to grow
like they would be expected to do in the
transplant in the patient
then you really have to perform some
other kind of potency assay
in that review mike watts also um
reviewed some of the literature i've
shown a couple of references here
where if you look um at
people that have really investigated the
effects of
storage conditions on hematopoietic stem
cell
potency you can see that they all come
to the same conclusion that the
assessment of the viability of cd34
frequency
can fail in some cases to predict the
effects on potency
which can be observed using the cfu so a
lot of the papers will always
validate whatever process they're doing
based on the cfu assay
for example paper and yang from yang in
2011
concluded that if there was a problem
with the rape controlled freezer and
anything was there was any interruption
you would definitely have to use a cfu
assay to affect the potency and the
effects
uh the effects on potency of the product
because cd34 failed to predict that
and also in a paper from jansen in 2009
he
investigated the transport of cells
because in a lot of cases
apheresis is not necessarily done in the
same place
where the patient's bone marrow
transplant is performed
so these cells tend to move around and
it takes a little bit of time to move
from where they're collected to where
they're
possibly going to be stored and or
frozen and he evaluated and you can see
in the orange box
and the table on the right that if you
stored
these cells for 48 hours in anything
warmer really than four degrees there
was an effect
in fact if you look over 10 degrees you
can see that
viable cd34 was still 80
on these fresh cells actually um and but
the cfu gm output was only 50 percent
so it really then goes to show you that
if you're actually
looking at different processing and
different storage conditions and you
expect
samples to actually not come to you
immediately
that you really have to think about
using the cfu assay to validate
all the processes you're doing not only
in the manipulating
of the cell stage but also after the
manipulation
between getting those cells from where
you're manipulating them to where you're
actually putting them in the patient
and just to summarize really this slide
shows that the cfu assay
then is a good potency and stability
assay because it does address
all these factors that affect the
potency and stability of hematopoietic
stem and progenitor cells
and that is the mode the time and the
temperature of collection and transport
the storage conditions the processing
methods the cryo present
preservation protocols these are
critical so if you want to
actually qualify your rate controlled
freezer again you have to use the cfu
assay
to get um an appropriate response
and on how that affects the quality of
the cells
as well as your protocols which will
depend also on
water the volume all kinds of things
so just to summarize then the cfu assay
has been used
to identify the potency of the quality
of hematopoietic stem cells
it's correlated very well with
engraftment and for years
researchers actually use this assay to
evaluate all kinds of factors in
biochemical pathways involved in
hematopoietic stem and progenitor cell
engraftment
mobilization and homing and really
evaluate
genes that were critical to the
maintenance of hematopoietic stem cell
homeostasis depended on knockout mice
and event
and recognizing that in those mice when
genes were knocked out what effect did
that have
on the output of the progenitors well
usually the cf you assay was the rita
in addition the cfu acid because it's
clonal allows you to really look at
changes in the frequency and the
morphology of hematopoietic stem cells
on a clonal level
and for hematological diseases for
example this has been
an advantage for something like
polycythemia vera
which has a jack mutation it's not in
every
cell in the body but to identify the
percentage
and get an idea of what we would call
disease load
you can actually pick colonies after the
cfu assay
and identify and get genetic
material from those and use that for pcr
to really evaluate
mutations or do any other kind of
genetic analysis
another sort of use of the cfu assay
especially when you're looking at gene
therapy
approaches is to recognize that you can
identify the frequency
of your particular manipulation and is
that
high enough for that for those cells and
for that disease to be corrected in
general
so a lot of different aspects of the cfu
assay can be used
and one of the ones also shown in the
diagram here
is the ability to evaluate the effects
of toxic compounds
and you can see for example in this act
example
that they looked at the expression of
mutation and could identify that in
bfues or
erythroid colonies that had the mutation
that when you added the drug
those were those were really eliminated
where there was very minor effects
on samples that didn't have that
mutation
so just before we close off then i just
wanted to give you some tips and tricks
about the standardization of the cfu
assay
as we recognize from this presentation
it's definitely a very versatile assay
can give you a lot of information
it hasn't been used more widely because
of the sources of variability
in setting up this assay and originally
it was more about media formulations in
the old days we didn't even have
recombinant cytokines so
making sure that you're always using a
media that's qualified appropriately
method cellulose has been the go-to for
the last 25 years
and stem cell technologies of course has
been offering qualified enough coat
media
for uh 25 years and we qualify our
using primary cells so the cells that
you are actually using
for these therapy products you also may
have to make sure you have standardized
practices ensuring
that your staff is trained on all the
procedures
and some procedures that you really have
to think about are
how are the cells received how are they
processed how are they thawed
what is your you know what are you using
for your viability stain for example
as well as how many cells to plate for
the cfu assay
it is it is linear in certain ranges so
it's always good to set up a couple of
different
concentrations to make sure you're in
that right linear range
but it is quantifiable so it can be
validated
um include when you're sops for
something like this to make sure that
it's done the same way
all the time the cell source that you
typically use
what are your expected viable ranges of
the cell and cell numbers
what's the appropriate media formulation
that you want to put those cells in and
we make this easy by offering optimized
formulations depending on the cell
source
and of course what are your ranges for
plating concentrations when you set up
this assay as i mentioned
it's linear but only in certain ranges
so just to give you an example i've
outlined some ranges here but you can
see for cd34
and rich cells you need very very little
cells in this assay
so typically you're setting up a lot of
assays to characterize those cells
the fact of the matter is you're always
going to have enough for the cfu you
don't need more than 500 per dish
honestly
and if you can set that up pre and post
engraftment that's going to give you a
lot of information about what changed
during that modification
one of the other variables when it comes
to the
cfu assay is scoring so you can see it
by the images on this slide this gives
you an example
of a plate of core blood mononuclear
cells
with about 80 colonies and
scoring these is not simple so you don't
need any fancy equipment
you just need an inverted microscope but
what's more important
is that your staff is well trained in
performing the assay and identifying the
qualities
and really that also means typically if
you're doing this for clinical reasons
that they participate in regular
training such as proficiency testing and
stem cell
at stem cell we provide that as well
also
we now have the ability to
automate csu colony scoring that sort of
eliminates that variability because it
can really standardize and
improve that reproducibility and
repeatability
as well as efficiency but when you have
different counters
different people sort of perceive
colonies in different ways
when you use something like an automated
score
especially with the algorithms that
we've developed that really does
identify the colonies based on
our knowledge of the colonies and how
they look but also recognizing how far
away they are
is really a mathematical calculation
that is not easily done
in your head so it's uh really good to
be able to visualize these and with
automated scoring you get
this sort of image that has marked up
colonies
where the blue circles are the what we
call
multi-potential gmm colonies whereas the
yellow ones are the myeloid
and the red ones are the erythroid or
the red circles
so you can really evaluate that if you
would have scored it that way
you can review the what the algorithm
has done
and sort of confirm that it's working
for you
so just to give you a little bit more
background information the stemvision
machine was developed really in 2011 and
it's now been used by numerous
core blood banks globally it accurately
identifies and classifies
and counts colonies from the cfu assay
from normal bone marrow cord blood and
mobilized peripheral blood and these
cell sources have been validated
uh first cell growth in methocult media
using more specifically the optimum
formulation
more recently in actually 2009
there was a cytotherapy paper that
standardized independently evaluated and
published and you can see from the title
here that
validation of the semi-automatic device
to standardize quantification
of cfu colonies so it really
allowed us to say that it was more of a
standardized
assay and you could use it sorry the
automated counting would improve
repeatability
inter-operator variability um and
comparison
for colony counts compared to what you
would otherwise get with manual counting
the other thing you notice from the
images that it it allows permanent
archiving of some very high quality
digital images of cultures so that you
can keep these
for all time anyone that's ever done
colony counting
recognize we do this on faith otherwise
um
and of course it's always hard to take
pictures of these because if you're not
looking at the whole
well it doesn't give you the whole story
and we've also helped standardize this
by synchronizing
this with a lot of other products
especially our methical product
and just before i get off the cfu assay
i just kind of wanted to point out that
with automated scoring which really
helps eliminate that variability you see
from counter to counter and what i've
been seeing more often
in teaching people to how to count
colonies
is that it's a situation where a lot of
people that have been trained on this
leave eventually so um to keep that
consistency in the lab it's nice to have
something that does this
automatically for you and gives you
these images
as i mentioned you get images that are
actually
you first take images with the stem
vision
and then after analysis you get a sort
of a data sheet
that gives you the numbers as well as a
marked up image
that you can review and every one of
these has a sample id
qualifier for easy identification of
what the sample was and that really
depends on what of course you put in
but once analyzed you get a worksheet
as well as you'll see this sort of
google whatever they call it image but
if you click on that what it does tell
you
is once you've analyzed your images
there is a readout of
what was the unit that you used what was
your plate id
what was your barcode id if you have if
you use barcode
what was your user id as well as all the
identifiers that you can put in
are captured here and time stamps so
that you know
that these images were taken 14 days
after
the cultures were initiated so that
you're well within your
qc parameters or set setup and analysis
so i'm going a little over time so i'm
just going to summarize now
and go back to the fact that um
can we ask the question and what are the
answers
uh does to see if you ask they meet the
requirements of a potency instability
assay
i'm going to start from the bottom
because i think that's a little easier
here
when you look at one of the criteria for
potency assay being that it should
indicate product stability and
consistency i think that's a resounding
yes for the cfu assay
as i've shown you there's a lot of
papers that whenever they're
evaluating a new potency possibly assay
or
they want to make sure that their
whatever
modification or storage condition or
whatever they've done
is actually working the cfu assay is
typically the assay that they use to
validate their processes
and it's one that the regulatory bodies
really ask when they go into the core
blood banks
how have you validated this process show
me that you have actually used the cfu
assay at least at some point
to validate those processes because it's
such a powerful lasting it's been
proven over many uh tens of years
that it is correlates with
um the engraftmen assay
the other thing a potency assay should
have is a quantitative readout
the cfu ac of course is quantitative
it's clonal
and it does allow one to evaluate
hematopoietic stem and progenitor
numbers before as well as after uh
transplantation to uh
and if you you can also use it to
identify the effects of drugs which i
showed you briefly
or the effects of cytokines on cells in
fact that's how we identified
hematopoietic cytokines was using this
efu assay replacing condition media
with recombinant cytokines to really
identify
their functional what they do
functionally
and if you compare patient samples pre
and post manipulation or treatment
that can really get rid of that as we
discussed at the beginning
inherent donor variability for these
products
um does it demonstrate product activity
well i think this is also an easy yes
because
again more than 30 years of research
have shown that the cfu assay correlates
with the in graft ability this was
originally of course done in most models
but
i've shown you evidence in publications
that say yes this also
uh is true when you move into
translational studies and clinical
trials
and can it be validated well the cfu
assay has been validated in some cases
for different purposes
like um the ability to identify
maximum tolerated dose of
chemotherapeutics by
adding drugs into the cfu assay and
looking at ic90 concentrations for
example
but in this case it really depends on
your application
and the patient's response observed in
the clinical trial so
if you're how you're using the cfu assay
for example if you've done
genetic manipulation you can first use
it to understand
you have a good product all your cells
are growing but then you can go in
possibly and pick clones
and look at the number of clones that
actually express the modification
and identify a range possibly of which
you would have observed from the
clinical trials
that is important in giving you a
successful transplant
so it's always good to set it up at the
front because it could also not only
be a potency and stability assay but
possibly also
important in the identity of the product
and possibly the release
so i'll stop now thank you very much for
listening to
this presentation and all entertain
questions
thank you dr damon for your excellent
and informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
if you'd like if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for wow we
have some great questions already coming
in
dr damon let's start with this one
can you define and give a small
background
about cfu assay
sure uh thanks christy yeah that's a
really good question i didn't go into it
a lot in this presentation
stem cell technologies does offer
training courses and in fact
i'm usually the one that shows up for
those um if you want one in your
institute of course now
we're looking at more virtual options so
hopefully those will be out soon
um the reality of the cfu assay is as a
biological assay is the concept
of really being to identify those cells
that have that proliferative potential
exterval so when you have mature blood
cells
proliferation really slows down as those
cells mature so we know that
except with the exception of mast cells
mature cells don't really proliferate
so it's the ability to put those cells
as a progenitor
so you would plates or for bone marrow
for example
um 10 to the four cells that's a lot of
cells
but only typically around 50 to 100 of
those at that
concentration are actual progenitors
that will grow
so if you put that then in a semi-solid
media
where they grow in a spatially
identifiable way
you can really see those as independent
cones as colonies
and if you look at the cells within
those colonies you can get an idea
of the maturation in other words are
these myeloid are these erythroid are
these even granulocytes or are these
macrophages
now bear in mind this is for the um
myelopoiesis side of hematopoiesis
there isn't really a good option when it
comes to looking at colonies of the
lymphoid
lineages and that's really because those
cells do not completely mature
in the bone marrow they really are
thrown out of the bone marrow as a pro
like an immature pro cell and in some
cases you can look at
mouse probes for example in the cfu but
that's about it
but for human cells those really go out
of the bone marrow and they do their
final maturation
in the thymus so they take a lot longer
to mature
it isn't just done in one little uh
couple weak assay
it needs a lot more changing of media
formulations and substrates that those
cells see
so lymphoid don't really work the same
way there are
different ways to expand those out so
the cfu is kind of
one that we recognize when it comes to
the myopoetic pathway
that we could really identify in a
really short period of time or at least
time that we didn't have to change media
because if you're doing it in something
like methylcellulose or in the old days
they used to do this in sloppy agar
for clonal identification you really
can't change the media
so that's sort of the background for
humans it takes 14 days
and then you get images like you saw on
the slide deck and then you have to
score those
and you have to go colony by colony so
on a inverted microscope of course
you need training so that you kind of
get used to doing that it usually takes
a couple of months
and it also takes about five to seven
minutes a plate
and a well where something like
automated can be done
in a minute anyway that was a long
answer to a short question
thank you dr damon and does the fda
require the cfu essay
um the fda when it comes to guidances
always and you've seen some of them in
this in this podcast
are in this webinar sorry that you they
always refer to the cfu
like the cfu assay because historically
it was
as you saw um it was that fine in 1979
so there's just tons and tons of
research to show the applicability of
that assay to really quantify
those cells the reality though is it is
a hard assay to set up standardize and
then their subjectivity
when it comes to calmly counting in the
old days that was a lot worse
because you didn't have necessarily very
standardized media products that has
improved obviously over the years so it
becomes
something that could be standardized but
there's the other criteria around that
how are you counting yourself some
people
absolutely will not use tripan blue it
doesn't give you a good enough viability
measurement for example so 780d
has been uh suggested as a way to
standardize this
so standardizing has been difficult but
as a comparative
assay so if you know your cells up front
and you
do some manipulation or even for
diseases
patients will have the same see if you
output in their bone marrow mobilized
peripheral blood
until they have a disease so um it's
become a very important assay when it
comes to that
although the only place that the fda has
actually written it into a guidance
believe it or not
is the cfu assay for the qualification
of
uh therapeutic equal when it's produced
so that's the only place that actually
says you must perform a cfu assay
even for something like tv it used to be
done quite regularly
now of course with pcr and the jack
mutation there are other ways to
identify pv it can be used
for pv diagnosis but it isn't
necessarily required anymore
but so the fda suggested a lot
and if you're going to have a good
potency assay they really want you to
know that you've done the cfu and that
it actually correlates with the cfu
because there's so much literature on
that
but finding another potency assay has
been difficult and
there's been a lot of people looking at
that in the last 10 15
years and nothing has really stuck as of
yet
thank you dr damon and we have time for
just a few more questions but i want to
remind our audience
that those questions we are unable to
answer live today
and additionally those that come in
during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by dr damon via
the
email address you provided at the time
of registration
okay let's squeeze in a few more if the
viability and functionality
are very different what are the what is
the testing needed
for guaranteeing efficacy of the
treatment
yeah very good question um it is
quite correlative with a fresh product
um especially a fresh
fresh product that's used within six
hours then viability
and potency are very similar and
functional viability
or defined as functional viability the
reality is when you saw cells especially
or when you leave them too long
everything is dying if you leave them
too long especially at a really high
concentration
the data that i showed here from one of
the publications
was 48 hours we don't actually allow
anybody to send us samples to test
unless they're within the 24-hour window
so recognizing that
but to really test for functionality
and not just viability viability is
always just a dna stain
you have to incorporate some kind of
activity
biological activity that takes place in
those cells
after you fought them or after you've
manipulated them
some people for example are starting to
investigate and have some very good
correlative evidence that if you could
foster 34
cells and stimulate them with il-3 you
can see
stat phosphorylation i'm a big fan of
this i
did a lot of testing on stat 5 to show
how important it is to see that you get
that activation and phosphorylation
so you really know that you've got this
biological function and it
correlates very well with those ability
of cells to grow
it's just how do you do that in a
standardized way so
to me it was easier to standardize the
cfu which is why i think a lot of
research
has focused on that the reality of
having another standardized assay
it would be great to have something that
was shorter again always having to
compare it to the cfu but
hopefully one day that you can actually
see viability but you have to show some
kind of biological
function for t cells for example you're
gonna have to show some kind of
effective function that it actually
affects the cells that you say it's
going to affect
and not just say oh they're viable
thank you dr damon and we'll wrap with
this final question
why would cells identified as cd34
positive
not in graft another good one
yeah this has become a lot more
um recognized recently so
despite again the fact and i was
involved in studies in the 90s so
i actually watched it happen live but um
more recently there's still
new information that's really allowing
us to understand those
um sorry what was the question again
yes um why would a story why would cells
identified as cd 34 positive naughty
before
right so cd34 we really recognize even
though
originally we thought it was a pure
population nothing is a pure population
when it comes to hematopoietic
differentiation it actually seems more
now
based on techniques that we've been able
to researchers have been able to employ
with single cells
and single cell imaging and genetic
analysis that it's a continuum
that the cell started hematopoietic stem
cells and
although on their surface they're still
cd34
that's a mixed cell population and some
of the cells are actually already
recognizing
and becoming fake determined that we
can't tell
by expression on their cell surface so
there's a lot of things that are
going on epigenetic changes that are
happening that we just don't see on the
cell surface
that start to split those cells into an
engraftable
self-renewing population which is very
slow growing because
normally a hematopoietic stem cell stays
stemmed by quiescence
so that population is slow growing as it
is and it gets overtaken really
by a population that does an asymmetric
division
not a symmetric self-renewing division
but an asymmetric division
still cd34 positive but now is state
committed
to one of the lineages and starts to
roll down that pathway
so cd34 is sort of encompasses and it's
one of the reasons we changed the
definition of hematopoietic stem
and hematopoietic progenitors to
hematopoietic stem progenitors
as we've realized over time that both
these populations are still cb34
positive and other markers
it's been difficult although more
recently you've seen them
and i outlined them in these slides that
you can start to pick that apart a
little bit better and really identify
which ones are still in graftable and
immature
and only doing self-renewing divisions
versus those that have done that
asymmetric division
and are starting to become fate
committed
thank you dr damon now before we go i do
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
there were so many questions we were
unable to answer and
again those will be addressed via the
email address you provided
at the time of registration i would once
again like to thank dr
jackie damon for her time today and for
her important research
we'd also like to thank labrutz and our
sponsor stemcell technologies
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed on
demand
and labberts will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and hope you have a great day
thank you